so vacation is over you're headed back
in a week we start season five I'm
really I don't want a good question
I don't want to spoil too much of it
obviously I don't know too much hi there
what I could presume is that we're gonna
see I mean if she's trapped in our time
nor Alan so I think we're probably gonna
see Barry trying to help her figure out
a way to get back to her time and yeah
see Barry and iris interacting with a
adult version of their chai I mean it's
gonna be really cool it's gonna be
really cool we're gonna see a new
speedster so get ready why do you think
every time there's a speedster they have
to say run Barry run or one Wally run
and I'm wondering if we're gonna get a
run Nora I would imagine without a doubt
we will hear Barry say run Nora run at
some point I don't know I think it was
just Tom made that line just like you
know so famous it's like it's just
classic flash but other than that I mean
I don't know I mean I would imagine if
we can stay on the air long enough well
we probably will see them have a kid
which we've so now right which now we've
seen yeah a stove at the end of lesson
right but I'm more thinking like when it
happened a baby but we'll see so I'm
excited to see what we're gonna do with
next year that with the mystery girl I
hope everyone is all the finale in a
world where you're heading back up soon
have you seen a first script yet no I'm
supposed to get it this week actually
real and I'm meeting with Todd helping
our ep showrunner on Monday so I'll get
the lowdown before I go back up time
travel was always yeah fun thing to do
we didn't really do it last year I
didn't think you very intentionally but
no the time trial stuff is fun it got
confusing for sure the sabotage so we
were late people asked me questions
about saboteur and I'm like I don't know
but no I like that stuff yeah I like the
Tom trip time travel stuff do you think
eventually you'll jump beyond the camera
and do it do you have any interest in
doing it flash has definitely made me
want to be a director which I did not
know about myself it wasn't the case
before flash just
because I've now spent you know
thousands of hours on set yeah so I
definitely want to do it but I've never
wanted to direct flash I always think
that's I think it's because it seems
impossible to me but I've been talking
about it a lot recently I think like
I'll probably set my sights on like
whatever our last season is right and
like kind of maybe do one that season
like how many more seasons do you think
the flash is gonna do what are we doing
five uh at least I would say what at
least three would be a safe bet we'll
see though I don't know you
anything could happen so I don't know I
mean it's a teen season strong in the
ratings for CW yeah any time I've ever
been around the show internally they're
like it'll this is one thing I've heard
said out loud the show can go we'll go
as long as grant wants it to go can I do
that you're gonna say that now I'm the
bad guy when it's not so that means 20
seasons Spiderman love Tom Holland
that's spider-man I love Andrew Garfield
too while we're talking about it
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of comic-con stuff to talk about
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're also doing a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do tent to that just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so I'll
name a new winner at the end of this but
some really interesting details Grant
Gustin revealing about season 5 I loved
the joke about the person asking him if
he would say run or a run to Nora and
he's like Oh most definitely
they say it to every speedster on the
show of course they would have Barry say
it to his daughter but he also confirms
that she's stuck in the past not there
because she wants to be there there
because she's stuck there but he doesn't
reveal whether or not it has anything to
do with the reason that you Barth on got
stuck in the past that was more of a
paradoxical situation whereby he went
back to kill Barry Allen's mother
because he could not kill Barry because
that would prevent him from becoming the
reverse-flash but in doing so prevented
Barry from becoming the flash for a
couple more years which then in turn
robbed him
of the speedforce forcing him to stay
there for the next ten years and
creating Bertie as the next flash faster
than he would have normally become the
flash so I think we also have to
consider that part of Nora's mistake is
the fact that she's stuck in the past
like she realizes that she's stuck and
goes I think I did something really bad
because I'm stuck in the past so this is
a tip of the iceberg remember a lot of
what her conflict is is stuff that's
happening in that post-apocalyptic
future timeline still a lot of theories
about that because of what legends of
tomorrow did with that timeline
metahumans were outlawed there was a
flash comic book story where Wally West
meets the tornado twins for the first
time Barry Allen's children in when he
first meets them in their future
metahumans have been outlawed so they
have to hide the fact that they have
superpowers
based on the way they described this
season's villain who were calling cicada
they might give him a different name but
the way that they describe him sounds
like he's cicada from the comics
systematically killing off metahumans it
just sounds like there's a situation in
Nora's time where she's not allowed to
freely be the flash like it's very
dangerous for her he also confirms he
wants to direct an episode and whatever
their final season is and then I love
the person right after that one question
like the next person after the question
about him directing was asking how many
seasons they would go for so even though
Kevin Smith doubles down with us 20
seasons it could go forever Grant says
bare minimum eight seasons a lot of that
just has to do with the syndication
numbers the flash right now crushes all
other CW shows in terms of ratings so
other shows will get cancelled long
before the flash ever gets cancelled but
when you go beyond eight seasons it's
just hard to predict that far into the
future based on the way that viewership
is going like people are transitioning
to a streaming model so that's gonna
change the way that people watch the
show which will change the way that they
monetize the show so just don't assume
that it's gonna go for ten seasons but I
do think that they have a pretty solid
shot of making it to that future
newspaper date the 2024 where Barry dies
during crisis on Infinite Earths it
would be really weird for them to keep
teasing that for the last five years and
then not to make it to that moment so if
they do get cancelled before that they
will probably find a way to do that
moment without having to wait til season
but getting into San Diego comic-con
next big convention that's coming up in
less than a month so what's happening is
is all the DC shows are having their
panels on Saturday night that's the same
night as all the big movie panels so
we'll get that flash season 5 trailer on
the same night that we get the Aquaman
trailer and rumored to get a Shazam
trailer and I don't know what kind of
footage they're gonna show off for a
Wonder Woman but they are gonna do a
special presentation they call it for
Wonder Woman it might just be like that
Justice League behind-the-scenes reel
that they did a couple years ago because
they had just started shooting it and
they've only been shooting Wonder Woman
for a couple of weeks now but we might
get a better look at what cheetahs
costume is gonna look like they actually
hired a special-effects prosthetics
person so it sounds like some of
cheetahs costume will be practical and
you'll see two different versions of
Kristen Wiig like the human version then
once she becomes cheetah you see we go
full-blown comic-book cheetah but the
other really cool thing is that they
confirmed that there's gonna be a Young
Justice season 3 panel that's gonna
happen on Friday morning they are
bringing a trailer so I'm assuming that
they're gonna drop that on line if they
do I will totally do a video for that
Saturday will be a little bit weird
because there'll be so many things
dropping but don't worry I'll figure
that out when we get a little bit closer
not everybody has announced what all
their panels are because that doesn't
get into any of the Marvel stuff that's
happening between Sony and Fox as of
right now Titans in the DC streaming
service is supposed to drop sometime
towards the end of August but they
haven't announced a Titans comic-con
panel which is really weird everybody's
kind of confused about it so I'll try to
dig up some more information and do a
video about that later this week but
just expect to hear more news about
what's going on with comic-con this week
studios are making their announcements
and we actually just found out that
Jeremy Irons Alfred from the DC movies
is going to be in The Watchmen HBO TV
series we don't know who he's gonna be
playing it's definitely not gonna be
Alfred so it'll be kind of weird but
they did that in the Marvel Universe
where you have alfre woodard from Civil
War going to Luke Cage in the Marvel
Netflix series and play a completely
different character think of it as the
exact same thing as that but there's not
gonna be a watchman comic-con panel
they're still shooting that right now
it's gonna drop next year so we will be
doing Watchmen HBO episodes sometime
next
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner mad Titan Thanos please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for the Avengers for
comic-con panel that I just posted and
click here for my big Aquaman preview
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you